welcome back I'm now going to introduce
you to the concepts of work and energy
and these are two words that are sure
you use in your everyday life already
and you have some notion of what they
mean but maybe just not in the physics
context although they're not completely
unrelated so work and you know what work
is work is when you do something you go
to work you make a living in physics
work is and I'm going to use a lot of
words and and and they actually end up
being kind of circular in their
definitions but I think when we start
doing the math you'll start to get at
least a slightly more intuitive notion
of what they all are so work is energy
transferred by a force so I'll write
that down energy transferred and I got
this from Wikipedia cuz I wanted a good
I guess relatively intuitive definition
energy transferred by a force and that
makes reasonable sense to me but then
you're wondering well I know what a
force is you know force is mass times
acceleration but but what is energy and
then I looked up energy on Wikipedia and
I found this well entertaining but it
also I think says tells you something
that these are just concepts that we use
to I guess work with what we perceive as
motion and force and and work and all of
these types of things but they really
aren't independent notions they're
they're related
so wikipedia defines energy as the
ability to do work so they kind of use
each other to define each other ability
to do to do work which is frankly as
good of a definition as as I could find
and so with just the words these kind of
don't give you much information so what
I'm going to do is move on to the
equations and this will give you more
quantitative feel of what these words
mean
so the definition of work in mechanics
work is equal to Force Times distance so
let's say that I have a block and let me
do it in a different color just because
this yellow might be getting tedious and
I apply a force of let's say I apply
force of 10 Newtons
ten Newtons and I move that block by
fourth by applying a force of ten yinz I
I move that block let's say I move it I
don't know
seven meters seven meters so the work
that I applied to that block or the
energy that I transferred to that block
the work is equal to the force which is
ten Newton's ten Newton's times the
distance times seven meters and that it
would equal seventy ten times seven
Newton meters so Newton meters is
one-one I guess way of describing work
and this is also defined as one Joule
and I'll do another presentation on all
of the things that a Joule did but Joule
is the unit of work and it's also the
unit of energy and they're kind of
transferable because if we look at the
definitions that wikipedia gave us work
as energy transferred by a force and
energy is the ability to do work so I'll
leave these this relatively circular
definition alone now but we'll use this
definition which I think helps us a
little bit more to understand the types
of work we can do and then what kind of
energy we are actually are transferring
to an object when we do that type of
work so let me do some examples let's
say I have a block I have a block of
mass M I have a block of mass M and it
starts at rest and then I apply force
let's say I apply a force F for a
distance for a distance of I think you
can guess what the distance I'm going to
apply it is for a distance of D so I'm
pushing on this block with a force of F
for a distance of D and what I want to
figure out is well we know what the work
is the I mean by definition whoops work
is equal to this force
times this distance that I'm applying
the block that I'm push that I'm pushing
the block but what is the velocity going
to be of this block over here right it's
going to be something somewhat faster
right because force isn't and I'm
assuming that this is frictionless on on
here so force isn't just moving the
block with a constant velocity force is
equal to mass times acceleration so I'm
actually going to be accelerating in the
block so even though it's stationary
here by the time we get to this point
over here that block is going to have
some some some some velocity we don't
know what it is because we're using with
using all variables we're not using
numbers but let's figure out what it is
in terms of V so if you remember your
Yorkie pneumatics equations and if you
don't you might want to go back or if
you've never seen the videos there's a
whole set of videos on projectile motion
and kinematics but we figured out that
when we're accelerating an object over
distance that the final velocity let me
change colors just for variety the final
velocity squared is equal to the initial
velocity squared plus two times the
acceleration times the distance and we
proved this back then so I won't redo it
now but in this situation what's the
initial velocity well the initial
velocity was zero right so the equation
becomes VF squared is equal to two times
the acceleration times the distance and
then we could rewrite the acceleration
in terms of what the force and the mass
right so what is the acceleration
well F equals MA or acceleration is
equal to force divided by mass so we get
VF squared is equal to two times the
force divided by the mass times the
distance and then we could take the
square root of both sides if we want and
we get the final velocity of this block
at this point is going to be equal to
the square root the square root of two
times force
times distance divided by mass and so
that's how we could we could figure it
out and and there's something
interesting going on here there's
something interesting and this what we
did just now do you see something that
looks a little bit like work well sure
you have this Force Times distance
expression right here force times
distance right here so let's let's write
another equation if we if we know the
the given amount of velocity something
has if we can figure out how much work
needed to be put into the system to get
to that velocity well we can just
replace Force Times distance with work
right because work is equal to Force
Times distance so we could let's go
straight from this equation because we
don't have to Reese quare it so we get
VF squared is equal to 2 times force
times distance that's work took that
definition right here 2 times work
divided by the mass let's multiply both
sides of this equation times the mass so
you get mass times the velocity and we
don't have to write I'm gonna get rid of
this F because we know that we started
at rest and that the velocity is going
to be let's just call it V so M times V
squared is equal to 2 times the work or
let's divide both sides by 2 or that the
work is equal to M V squared over 2 just
divide both sides by 2 and of course the
unit here is joules so this is
interesting now if I know the velocity
of an object if I know the velocity of
an object I can figure out using this
formula which hopefully wasn't too
complicated to derive I can figure out
how much work was imputed into that
object to get it to that velocity and
this by definition is called kinetic
energy this is kinetic energy and once
again the definition that that wikipedia
gives us is the energy due to motion or
the work needed to accelerate from from
an object from being stationary to its
current velocity and I'm actually almost
out of time but what I will do is I will
leave you with this formula that kinetic
energy is mass times
City Square divided by 2 or 1/2 MV
squared it's a very common formula and
I'll leave you that and and that is one
form of energy and and I'll leave you
with that idea and in the next video I
will show you another form of energy and
then I will introduce you to the law of
conservation of energy and that's where
things become useful because you can see
how one form of energy can be converted
to another to figure out what happens to
an object I'll see you soon